[Music]
Frank Jackson who's blue on his hip
shayana up against Ted Davis and go back
at home I can't do a thing about it to
patients by Xion good patience by Zion
come back to the Shaw hands for finish
for sprint
well if you're gonna play the type of
pace to Jim Boylan once you have to have
a second unit that can be productive
Xylo if sit against some of those ball
handling skills I'll just watch a little
bit of the handle here see once he makes
that move now the bells
[Applause]
firstly for the powell since way back in
the second quarter I wanna hear Enzo
this young man is impressive his ability
to put the ball on the floor create
contact get finished through the contact
it's not easy
Williams will trot Williamson
another Thunderer's Jam third of the
night for Zion Williamson now the only
bad shot he's taken - yes very very good
as soot observations
I like Heart Walk Hall Williamson this
time scoop layup Zion tonight is right
on the money you can see he's going to
take it got a crossover and go Strong's
at all reddish over to Collins delicates
come away
Monza want the bounce holiday give it
goes to Zion holiday the rebound quick
outlet to put there it is ball throws it
up way inside lays it down
great unselfish play right there by ball
guy in the open floor
is just beautiful to see mainly because
he runs so hard so crossover loses
angles Zion stays
i'ma say it again Joe that's not normal
second effort second effort before
anybody else there he's dead he's the
only one that's off the ground the only
one that gets off the ground to staff
the second shot you see if you're not a
play the way they want to play and that
is last year they were third in the
ligand spline Oh again
there-there is nice move without the
ball
see he's easing if his man hesitates and
steps away from him to look to help out
on a dribbler
he's moving without the ball quickly
[Applause]
proper Bulls his way right to the hole
with the right hand and say explosion
then looking again is just one dribble
here one bounce one two step it goes
hard that's too late
what up at your boy Adam left go hit
that subscribe button for more videos
from Bleacher Report